yeah Lord
that's loops on my soul and praise all
the modders out there because modding is
hard
we I we just been so long trying to get
this mod to work because I I desperately
wanted to try out this recreation of the
Wizarding World in Minecraft
honestly I thought I had it ran around
like for two seconds when to get lunch
came back crashed then took another like
35 minutes just to get it to work but
you know what we're hearing it's all the
matters yes what's up Persia woo
shoutout to Julio
that's for y'all so yes thank you guys
so much
yes for being patient Oliver this
shout-out is that's for you bro so yeah
thank you guys so much for sticking by
Niko am Oliver Matthew Hopkins the whole
game wooden here and I'm hype so let's
get our Harry Potter on now it's alright
so we have the information in the chat
below there's also a lot of other things
you have to do to get this map to you're
a straight-up hacker guys a little
complicated for me this is all still a
work in progress
work in progress not officially released
yet but soon Tim and I'm very very
excited to actually play it and check it
out finally and also Thank You Julio for
coming to help us yes Willie Oh bless
you Julio so let's do it if you don't
know what we're gonna play we are
playing the Minecraft School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry Frick yeah half
to begin we are definitely doing
single-player wait as my mouse not that
low gonna be like this
Oh No why can't I move my mouth my mouth
oh no all right hold up one another
mouse is it the mouse maybe a controller
if there is support Jodie says I am here
don't pay good I was wondering when you
were gonna show up man the dark Neptune
can have a shout-out yeah man
it's for you yeah that's strange this
part works
hmm I just wanted so desperately plays
good clothes let's uh so strange because
in the menu it's fine maybe just the
title screen I don't know Matt in the
chat Matthew says there is a book at my
school what okay I know that's why PCs
cool because you get to like do all the
cool things exclusive disease-like
fan made stuff and everything like that
or enter I was hitting Enter and nothing
was going on but I'll try it without the
mouse oh you know what hmm yeah I was
using
I was like maybe I should have been
using the arrows okay hitting okay okay
gotcha
boom we're good see you let's see
there's a few settings I need to adjust
click chat settings replicate the chat
settings below I can be able to see this
mm-hmm
Theo asks if we play for tonight um I do
not I played it a little bit when a
frisky
but I wasn't good at building in the
middle of a fight me too it's probably
the biggest turnoff for me I tried it
it's free you know oh my goodness I hope
I can remember this this is a lot
I might just skip it Matt can download
the mods cuz he just has a laptop he
says really oh man I didn't know what it
was um
it all looks pretty much the same I
think maybe you can't handle it I don't
know I'm just making sure I had all the
right things all right you know what I'm
sure he'll be it's fine um spin asks is
this already fully released as far as I
know no it's still an alpha do you see
the orange circle in the frame above yes
[Music]
and click options then click video
settings
Spidey asks what we play resin evil 3
when it comes out oh my god we will we
hecka will just it's fine my patience is
very limited right now oops sorry
let me not ruin the cutscene
[Music]
Wow I know this is amazing
where's Dumbledore where's the oh my god
I can't wait yeah there we go lumberjack
I knew there was something about this
month in particular that was actually
more accessible than a lot of other ones
I just struggled with them
wow you're here wait oh there we go now
it's an awfully big room for it can't be
Harry's room I mean unless it's the room
from the sequel's yeah exactly this is a
deadly second room problem this is so oh
you gotta check out your old room
this is totally okay so we're in the
future oh wait also I should add we are
in Harry Potter we're actually just a
regular horror scrub oh no now I'm
remembering that's okay Wow awesome
we've been accepted but we obviously
obviously like Harry Potter's neighbors
or something yeah we live in the same
neighborhood with the same model style
house Jodie asked oh yeah we played GTA
and Red Dead Redemption oh yeah baby
I was added to my inventory oh yeah I'd
probably be one of those kids that just
isn't magical figure what they're called
a muggle or wait no it's like we're both
their parents are magic but the kid
comes out not magic it's like Filch me
too you know
shout it out in the chat cuz that'd
probably be my luck yeah
go wait check box Jesse do a fortnight's
dream I don't know man we stink don't we
don't play we could get David he's a MVP
he at least knows what's going on at all
times with court night wait I didn't
close my house squib there we go web
yeah that's my Ashley whoo now she's in
there making fun of me she's like duh
see I knew I knew mud blood but not
squid yeah we don't say that here
getting school supplies growing up was
one of my favorite things in the world
for some reason don't ask oh no no oh
wow it's a little voodoo head in there
Persia I know what you mean though like
ironically as much as I didn't like
school preparing for school and like
binders and pencils was fun chopping for
that
look at this dude well we already know
in the night buses we are very prepared
oh yeah we're ready Brendan says the
Harry Potter books are way too long so
are the movies but you should give them
a chance if you haven't seen them all of
them do it now Brandi Coldren about to
get lit woo dark Neptune we play siege
I'm one of the cod myself squeaky brakes
all right let me just did i sir not from
the star is gonna be like that
oh man hope 9:00 Bob Jones and a chat
welcome welcome back friend all right
[Music]
all right we've made it and I think I
can talk to people now that dream was -
business yeah
anywho I got some shopping Wow no we got
to get we got to get lit at fleet Colton
first Dylan says I'm on the fifth look
right now nice hmm you guys haven't
listened to them the audiobooks are also
really really good I do share voiced by
Jim Dale that's correct so amazing even
does the voices it's great and you make
something to make some original voices -
I want a butter here Brady mercury we're
broke Wow now I'm hungry
look at Jodi's flexing in the chat I can
read the biggest Harry Potter book in 24
hours although this is a this is also
work Perl was for a while member bad
times good times though good times here
bad times here
neater looking again very good all you
have to do an artery to open it tap on
that brick there I love that scene it's
like tap tap tap and then it's so funny
movie too because he totally misses one
of the bricks and it's like lumberjack
guts lumberjack jeff says the Diagon
Alley entrance is my favorite thing ever
in this map it is very important see we
were just talking about how much we
loved look there it is come on do the
cool CG effect
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I read through the series twice a minute
listen to the audio at least five -
Mariah says this looks amazing
Wow go get our books our one you did
was it one of those like $100 ones that
like interacts with the world around you
know folks broomsticks Leakey already
got one why you flexing yeah what are
you doing here oh man oh man I want to
go everywhere I'm like should I just
walk into every Irish I go and order the
quest for rent Wow yeah be sick Julius
in the chat has a tip for us but it's
looking okay right now I don't want to I
don't want to mess with it it goes took
us a while to get here he's a just
suggesting a video settings to make it
look even we don't want to goof it up
wasn't good enough to memorise the
settings they were telling me to do
where's like the joke shop still in
business baby these block your we have
seven bucks hmm seven gold green watts
is the wave I need to get some new
offers sorry I keep jumping for
something
Wow mini-map go to Settings video
setting huh oh you're doing it render
distance 29 Bart
oh no far plus that's what it says on
the top right I was like it says fart
like the all the townspeople here hmm I
was very kind of you Alejandra he says
along hey guys long time fan of you guys
just wanted to say hi love you guys and
hope you continue doing what you do on
this channel males so nice of you thanks
for tuning in alejandro try again
oh i mean it's looking fine out it looks
good I'm already very impressed
looks like Hedwig okay he's probably got
mail to deliver out of my way y'all
Hogwarts not yet quality
Gringotts oh oh there it is on the right
on the bottom towards the bottom oh yeah
yeah and set it to 3 instead of maximum
bro are you sure bro wait hmm oh oh
that's not gonna mess this up I'm not
sure oh no oh no yeah well we'll just
learn riperoni learn we're not gonna
mess with any settings that's low key
what I was scared though me too
I was like mm-hmm hands off for me there
he took us a while to get here this mod
luckily we only like did a couple of
things over
for shell oh man no worries it's not
your fault Julius honestly you should
have been so easy to install this mod
for us but for some reason on this ski
we're back at the wizard so it
definitely kept our progress it's gonna
know Julius wasn't at least trolling
he's like defeated oh that's a funny way
to put it yeah for those of you just
tuning in look have you ever seen that
GTA 5 video it's like first you're
playing as Franklin and it's in first
person you walk up to a guy and you you
negatively respond to him he's like a
man like f you and then he's like he's
like what you want to start a fight and
then you pull your gun he's like I'd
like to apologize the way Julia said I
apologize made me think of that Wow
still so still so very impressed
what dedicated both in the Minecraft
field and Harry Potter I like I don't
know if I could ever do anything like
this I've ever played Minecraft wasn't
even to play it was to just build stuff
[Laughter]
Wow oh I see it I see hmm in the other
map I saw when like you're outside
everyone's like hmm hmm and then you
come in here now like those creepy
Goblin eyes how did you think wow she's
just talking to somebody made us some
money purchase online purchase
schoolbooks you're living for this Jodie
in the chat hmm that's the language here
Wow now did you play much minecraft
first not now not now but back then I
used to just create like oh cool I have
not and I just don't I don't know I
never really got into it it was like a
fad that just went over my head but it's
always been amazing to see what people
can do I've seen like the Star Trek
Enterprise being Bill I've seen so many
models and they're pretty astounding
this is just another great example of
that sorry picking my mouth alright yeah
I I used to always watch time lapses -
oh yeah those were big for a long time
all the fenders when I went to Universal
they have a whole little ceremony and
they pick one person out of the crowd to
dude the whole magical part where they
test the wand like books and some glass
or whatever just like in the movie I was
so jealous it wasn't me but it's also
like you know they want to like okay I
was kind of just wandering that's okay
profits Wow someone said stairs left of
Bank okay
hey you were up here though Oh we'll see
maybe we need to explore some more I do
hear more people are we going to the
leaky cauldron oh no it says okay our
mission is to locate Ollivanders wand
shop with this thing so this dude is a
fan of minecraft Harry Potter and vine
videos will Hughes in the chat thanks
for joining us my dudes
oh goodness that was funny nice little
strange Easter egg I know but I think we
say that every Wednesday around here for
show Oh was there another staircase
inside that little room I didn't see
that's that was always one thing about
Minecraft the doorways are so small I've
missed them every single time I go
inside still though it's fun to explore
around
we'll find it eventually money yeah an
apple don't eat that Apple
books doesn't care they need books he
said yeah what book do you need out of
all these and some free money over there
you stole Freddie going yeah what the
heck yeah sell me my books homie
he didn't have any other points of
conversation I'm just like happy - nice
to see a new face hmm yeah this looks
like the one
Oh what was that
that scared me whatever Oh dog they just
made the bookshelves out of doors
so me trying to open the door okay all
right it was must be a decorative thing
not an actual door that's funny unless
the books are in there what the heck
maybe we have to do I know he said
locate fluorescent bulbs
okay yeah I did go the wrong story okay
someone in the chat says let's see oh
there is an arrow I see it Yammer thank
you I just saw a book story that's all
right
who Knockturn alley it's so dark no no
no don't ever go there we seen the
movies making it up there by mistake but
that's it
[Music]
Wow there's the there's the shop again
the Weasley brothers joke shop I do need
to get my robes also he do this out of
order or like it's it's fine if you do
[Music]
Wow being fitted up Oh Oh No I was gonna
say if it's a Malfoy child do you okay
good yeah good thing it's only fifty
gold you can go all out
although do you see your own character
ever as early well it just said rope so
I'm just gonna go four ropes for now if
I have enough money later
for sure we can always come back
there's just money lying around all over
the place oh no I meant like a cuckoo
bazoo says hello yeah oh yeah back
string I'll take that car shuffling
cards absolutely that's cool though at
least man casinos in the wizarding wrong
let's live everyone's cheating though
Wow
I do father says it would have been to
play for my house and I must say I agree
ya know what house you'll be in yurts so
you're playing like you're playing as
someone else they're aged in the same
timeline but you're not Harry not sure
where's like eff off goodbye for the two
for the grocery team it's people they
feel sorry for you see there's roasting
you got no money
oh my god your brains good job just
literally channeling like well I didn't
I wasn't sure if it was gonna affect my
later decision like oh wow he's getting
sorted into later you know so I didn't
want to mess it up alright you should be
on the team clearly you've got no brains
I'm wow you're still talking anyone wow
he's really going in oh this okay this
is like I think they should keep in all
those new families and I'll let anymore
I don't mean you don't hmm
and now he's talking trash about Rey
riddle says that face will haunt my
dreams hmm hmm enough of you Malfoy
gizmo in the chat yeah I don't need your
assistance anymore hmm sick robed up
[Music]
where's the draco hairs those bodies
yeah they're all Blockheads you know
it's probably textured on the back of
his head but it won't stick up I don't
think yeah slicked-back you know you
know how Malfoy desert I just saw this
circular little thing and I remembered
when I got my
IRL oh you're right yeah Bob Jones this
is unacceptable I'm with you oh okay
before you you see those of us who study
want Laurie know that the wand chooses
the wizard it's just not always clear as
to why you see the best results always
come when there is the strongest
affinity between the wizard and the ones
I put aside if you want I think you
might I think might be suitable here in
the shop can you find those for me okay
isn't that your job now I'm just getting
to it I got it I got this I will find
the ones that she'll soon Mert says you
should buy a hat little bro I wonder if
it's gonna have a notification or yeah
it's gonna be highlighted or something
[Music]
once I get my one okay so I have to find
three what that would ruin everything
where are these blonds once I find the
phrasing I know what it looks like
you got a search oh my goodness is there
a ladder he's like there's three wands
around here oh there we go in the box
and you got one hmm
another staircase dang Ollivander oh
you're down here this is where the bad
ones are yeah no one Ollivander I got
one for you yes or no the little compass
isn't even helping us out Oh on the left
was that one right that's the first one
I'm sorry sorry do you play the Harry
Potter games for like the Xbox or
Playstation one got it sorry you were
saying you picked it I know yeah it's
right there
Oh the Mike is blocking a monitor a
little bit huh it's like a little bit of
a shadow the only Harry Potter games
I've played are the Lego ones and oh I
didn't jump on that cuz I was scared
that my battery would just die again
like it did with Pokemon go you got all
three time to see which one is right for
you
Ollivanders place is dark y'all I can't
no no no no no no that's air hmm
Ollivander one has a core of a powerful
magical substance we use unicorn here as
Phoenix tail feathers and the hearts
dreams of dragons no two Ollivander
wands are the scene just true tea
unicorns dragons or Phoenix's are quite
the same and of course you will never
get such good results with another
Wizards long hmm it's so Lord well here
we are try this perhaps a wand of birch
15 inches flexible and swishy with
unicorn swish you know I reckon that
well perhaps it's no time to wreck your
shop lumberjack jeff says Ollivander I
found one and now I'm done I'm just
gonna take this one good it's working
Wow Ollivander are you not impressed bro
Oh ray riddle in the chat says I
remember playing the ps1 game right
before the first movie it came out
before the movie that's cool
I only played the first one and I played
it like a few years ago for the first
time and it was fun it was really cute
like ps1 game I think
man I'm gonna go home it's gonna sound
wrong but play with my wand
[Laughter]
I like how just now you're just armed at
all times but don't mess with me oh yeah
Jody and the chesses you should have
unlocked that door upstairs with Aloha
interesting
it said spells unlock okay we'll get
back to that though Jody good looking at
you because I did definitely already
forget like the image on the right it's
like the book standard you're broke wait
that makes sense
you're a year one after all like that
well you figured okay okay alright there
we go hey I got standard big spells so
that must mean hmm
get my learn on
wait I just straight up half of
marauders not I just right now yeah what
was it hiding inside a book Jodi says I
loved that book there you go
strapped alright so I think I was
supposed to buy the Hat and the other
thing to himself no biggie
now that you know how to we're just
finding it everywhere in this town in
Diagon Alley well very close fifa world
says stopping by showing some love from
NYC thank you fifa world you like NYC
I can't purchase a Hogwarts student what
[Music]
nice amount of gold excellent
oh you have to equip them I don't know
oh it's all dressed to the no how dare I
walk around without me no pants
No Deal you did it you got dressed man
if only every single morning I could get
that like Jodi says oh I think you can
get a pet I don't know they're telling
us believe worse for the owl breed no no
the Owlery is where they hang out before
they send messages it's like the mail
run you guys not
it's down here I'm gonna try to get a
pen I still have a little bit of cash to
spare yeah I need to buy snacks on the
on the train press f5 sways no don't no
Jeff don't be messing with us I don't
know that's kind of like close the game
like Halo and it would just like kick
you out of the game chicken coop
rare muggle asks how can I install this
mod that's for you
the mod is in the description
get your modding hat on cuz there's a
little extensive but you can achieve
these results lumberjack Jeff says I'm
not messing with you guys
f5 will show you your character look at
that it crashed the game bro what are
you doing was kidding yeah shags gaming
says hi guys hey welcome welcome to the
chat welcome to the stream yeah playing
a little Harry Potter modded minecraft
it's quite a mouthful
oh it's coming it's a little different
way you don't like have anybody's like
at this point in the movie you've been
introduced to you're too young
no we know butter B is like the
non-alcoholic one any Lea's confirming
at five is just a camera thingy we're
Hedberg oh I miss them
[Music]
Westminster here we are oh thank you
look it we got some love from the chat
and course as I love your videos guys
thanks for joining us
yeah Wow pick up pick up a little bit
lumberjack Jeff excuse me Jeff and the
chances also thank you for calling me
Jeff I'm used to being called lumberjack
got you Jeff who are these
what upshot who are these people
civilians oh why thank you appreciate it
guys right like I mentioned earlier all
the times I played Minecraft were not to
actually play minecraft it was just to
build in sandbox because I like to do
that type of stuff
oh yeah don't let the muggle see my wand
we're gonna call the police what happens
[Music]
so Maas
welcome it says hi guys oh oh is this
the building
David this is a Harry Potter mod on
minecraft maybe not so much a mod but a
map well map mod you know we got our
wand in our books in Diagon Alley I
think you just missed it there David but
we're starting off here now our next
mission is to go to the keys this right
we saw that earlier oh now we're right
under it okay doh Wow whoa you did some
sort of zoom zoom oh no just it hiccup a
little bit
wow so impressive you got pigeons
so satisfied I've never been to London
neither yeah we do sure ninety three
quarters think you mean plenty do you
that scares me every time that we don't
hiccup where's the station what's that
sign say is it is it helpful at all oh
no we have a little compass yeah I just
wanted to look at it who is this mod by
let's see it's another description the
flue network which is also absolutely
amazing like yeah it's all in the
description friend if you're interested
Salman and if you got a Minecraft on
your PC Wow jump the line Sam find a way
to get to platform 9 and 3/4 typo there
oh oh no there we go this is the Java
version of Minecraft space yeah so make
sure you're using the Java Edition I
didn't know there was a whole nother
edition called the Java Edition I think
that's what makes stuff like this
possible I see where were you now which
platform 9 those are the Weasleys aren't
they
not to worry dear
in a bit of a run don't be scared of
crash into it that's a very important
best to do it at a bit of a run if
you're nervous yeah just like the movie
of all the wheezes are looking at you
the game is crashes I'm skinny or it's
like that's the end of our demo what's
up oh no will confuse child who is this
yeah I was gonna say that because of his
little teeth he has a frog named Jeffrey
the Frog from its Wednesday my dears
is that the Frog
[Music]
hmm hmm
or did he mean on that side of the Train
know what we know oh they're all looking
at it where y'all lookin man
is your coat on the tracks no compass or
anything they're not giving any freebies
away Perry is that you oh my god it's
like hey Morgan
yeah he's a toad not a frog oh he's
always losing him just like the movies
just like the book Oh
park [ __ ]
what about spring jump or were you
already sprinting parkour Gore here we
go this is for you Neville we love you
oh damn it we're gonna miss the train
it's kidney Oh what wake up one clam
okay
[Music]
time to get on top of the train I need
to know this because I know later
there's platforming and if I don't get
those now
oh there really is later yeah
only Oh
let us let us pray like a good like a oh
dang it
long as the train doesn't leave we good
that's okay stop holding the spacebar
down what those baseboards to jump okay
all right there you go be getting better
come on Neville I know
making us do all this that little light
brown getting close they're getting
closer every time Jeff says I believe
well glad the Train settled down and
sounded like it was about to leave Oh
oh boy all there everyone standing on
the slab rooms like what is this guy do
it yeah
Alvaro is stressing out in the chat he's
John this is not VLC this is a fan-made
mod and it can be found in the
description if you're interested it's
not completed all the way yet is that
right Persian hey what's up that's cool
your apex like climbing that wall
[Applause]
this must be part of the puzzle like
find the right boxes that you can jump
on to Shaggs believe shag says you guys
will make it if you believe we have to
believe Persia oh you're so close
that you're gonna like died here at
Kings Cross yeah let go let's face it
you're in hey what's going on welcome to
The Scream today oh you're on the tracks
oh there you go thank goodness
[Music]
oh man the other levels are going to be
so hard if this is just like Kevin
Mitchell we got you we we figured that
out earlier the shift to run right yeah
there you go there you go
this damn toad oh you're so close my
life points right now oh the gamer guy
we have the information to download this
in the well the link is in the
description of this video and from there
you should be able to find the
directions there's a ladder on those
boxes yeah but it doesn't take you up
all the way does it
[Music]
where is your health Oh
okay
all right
there he is Trevor okay and of course I
didn't get the jump jump as late as
possible Jeff is like Leviosa yeah my
body over the hour Livio so the Frog the
F out of there the toad excuse me
Leviosa
press f to pay respects and collect very
good kevin mitchell says that's tell
isn't for nonliving items so we couldn't
have done it with the frog or us yeah I
wish we never spoke to you Neville the
way to hog ward we'll take the time to
buy all the snap
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
man didn't buy the snacks or anything oh
well do you see this there you go
he's helping out Harry right now I
really don't think he's here oh we can
talk to that guy my now I'm the only JJ
bubs it's a map
not so much yeah even have the am I
gonna get sorted I hope they do all the
Texas
stretch a little bit whatever like all
the apostrophes and it's talking there
well we're so excited to be here hungry
oh I thought he was like honest like
sitting on his knees or something yeah
so far away you're like ruddy a cup of
salt yeah I needed that after that
Trevor extravaganza I mean I produced
that really there keep up a grid JJ
Bub's asks this playable on a bad
computer I don't know man if he can run
Minecraft you've probably got a good
chance but I can't say for certain my
friend I know that I did need to
download something else felt like
Optifine to go with this yeah Jeff says
there's a lite version there you go I
would I would check out that discord
server thank you Jeff
yes how far did you make it in this map
are we on the boat oh this is the big
reveal I like that everything's just
like one little octave off from you
[Music]
Wow explore the turrets and towers get
lost in the fitt freedom forest oh they
know I mean they do that in the movie in
the books that's where you find for the
first time just like yeah Wow how
extensive is this can you play through
the whole first book is that what's
going on here um I saw something in the
disc read about someone speedrunning
this in like an hour and a half Oh which
movie is shorter than that
[Laughter]
Jeff says I finished it I should have
I'm a mod of discord server after all oh
cool right JJ we're like we're still
freaking out this is very cool yeah I'm
pretty obsessed with Harry Potter is
though the second I saw this did it
launched recently or like I haven't seen
an article about it it's like
free-to-play available now but not quiet
final oh sure sure adult mainsail this
looks amazing
yes yes yeah someone actually built all
this out the way kid
[Music]
slope in all right I want to go and
watch the movies you're still watching
ash let's do it tonight I love the first
one especially I wanna have a Harry
Potter theme like watch party and I want
to get like a bunch of the mini like
shot bottles and re label them into
potions and like do the whole theme oh
that's fun and then we can have like
those those bamboozled beans and like
throw up all over each other maybe just
me in the corner flu says the lag spikes
were getting our RAM issue we can lower
the render distance a little but I don't
know we were very scared
this afternoon installing all this and
we're like it's very oh there we go is
that the main like area like where the
Battle of Hogwarts ends it's like the
not the court or the courtyard
everything memories are flowing back
y'all when they had like the Knights
come yeah I thought that was so cool
were those elves mechanical sorry I saw
elves I'm pretty sure I saw like I wish
she started off as a little Catholic oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
man what time did we start how much time
do we have left is why I want to ask how
we're good then you have like another 25
minutes or so mm-hmm yes
I wonder what will be sorted into I
wonder if in this version of the
Minecraft map if we have any say in it
because like in the movies and the books
you you if you think it hard enough you
can sort of pick your your
Oh what am I thinking I think that well
I don't know if us talking to Malfoy I
made a difference in our mouths pic oh
yeah just in case
Wow all the candles in the Grand room of
the big dining room the Great Hall
that's it
[Music]
JJ bubs is still so impressed he's like
so dang cool even Dumbledore it's your
turn to get sorted y'all Christian hey
welcome it's a quiz you have to answer
like a Griffin if you want I mean I
don't know do you are it's it's in your
control
hi from Ukraine hello oh I wish I could
pronounce your name please tell me how
to pronounce alright I'm a Gryffindor
but every quiz I've ever taken has
actually put me in Raven cool that's
cool
every quiz I think the official
Pottermore quiz for me said I was
ravenclaw too and I was like I don't
know I'm not that cool to be in a
ravenclaw to be a ravenclaw how long
were they working on this I'm not sure
I'm sure someone in the discord has all
the information which of the following
would you most hate people to call you
given the choice would you rather invent
a potion that would guarantee you love
glory wisdom or power son shock no he's
using the wand in the thumbnail Jeff
says I'm a Hufflepuff a puffle a true
hufflepuff hey man I mean you're chill
bro they like to read - I believe
kickback oh there was more than one
answer ah no no can you go back return
no I don't know I don't want to F with
this oh man well look out for that
little arrow maybe some questions only
had four answers and the ones with the
arrows like this had multiple hope so
[Applause]
yeah that's where you just let the Beast
yeah oh my goodness I didn't know there
was more than who doesn't you know
there's just like beast all this
delicious food cédric back off
he's the Hufflepuff - Freddy boy there
you go Jeff robbed the description
hufflepuff are the generous caring and
friendly ravenclaw are the wise smart
and witty Slytherin are the devious and
such and Gryffindor are the bold the
brave and the daring very good
and yet ah they're up to no good and
they're gonna pass it down to you hmm
here new kid that's big that's serious
to solemnly swear there it is how do you
back out also mischief managed
that's it oh you can fast travel I think
they said you're free to explore maybe
after you've been in the room then you
can fast travel there I hope anyway oh
ok common room I don't think that's ever
been featured in the movies see all the
books I remember that fact they love to
read hufflepuffs and oh oh really oh
that's so cool the dormitory Wow so many
books everywhere I love this I wish I
read more or read I could I think yeah
right period I won't lie to you
I just don't read for enjoyment anyway
you know what I mean like I play games
and stuff of course you gotta make time
to read though
like we get right up in their face all
right let's go learn let's go learn Jeff
is saying you can still go into the
Gryffindor
I trust Jeff the wine cellar yeah for
teachers only we don't have Loomis yet
soon oh whoa busted right there
grown-ups around here all right I need
to leave here just walk up the grand
stairway Jeff says didn't you just oh
I'm not sure
hey yo more welcome to the chat welcome
to the stream or was it through the wine
cellar oh I don't think so
oh you know what that one the movie
that's so cool to see a ghost who is
that it are you back in the house so I'm
sure there's like an altar Oh Oh JJ says
actually made butter beer last night no
long nice you know what the the way the
I never had interest cuz the term like
butter beer kind of just sounded like
it'd be like a greasy drink but what is
it like a scotch that's why okay you
know I'm I'm I'm a moderate fan of
butterscotch flavored things I like
lollipops
I am but this whole castle is just oh so
amazing well Jeff says you can use the
map to teleport back to the Grand
Staircase if you want oh you were going
into like the Chamber of Secrets
where you I look away for one sec and
we're about to start the second movie
the Chamber of Secrets this is going so
well I love this it's so it's the
attention to details really nice true
Harry Potter fans know I want to do it
all yeah
only we had more time this is looking
that's so cool
Oh watch how they're gonna move on you
[Music]
fluffy that thing has a name yep JJ
still with the oh wait you were supposed
to go here huh this is how Harry Potter
gets in trouble I don't
it's like locate the charms classroom
you're like nah I'm gonna do my own
thing hey Universal Studios they have
like spiked butter beer don't they oh no
one is like like a slushie isn't it
something there's a differs two kinds I
remember hearing about this looks like
where they practice for Dumbledore's
aren't Army and the the Room of
Requirement
sort of looks like it like an empty Hall
dungeon thing listen
funny textures over the fire getting
lost in a digital version of it it's
still so amazing though there's no wrong
way to do this this is incredible
[Laughter]
Gryffindor on the way discovered I guess
if I walk into it I can fast travel to
it yeah okay that's what I thought
earlier I'm glad seems to appear that
way like the PlayStation one area you
can play an area in the ps1 game
you're like parkouring on shelves in
that game too legit loss I'm even trying
to use this compass and it's not by
Brandon thanks for stopping by good to
see you as always
oh by the way Brandon before you go I
finally got a switch it will be here in
like oh it happened it happened
Tetris ninety-nine streams all day every
day
Tetris pot there are no kids here and
stuff it's kind of weird when you're all
alone our music it's just like kind of
spooky you're late McGonigle is gonna
give you [ __ ] just like in the movie
alright he might be understanding
McGonigle though Sheen having I think I
found it I think Brandon says nice he
says nice get Skullgirls it's on a
switch that's cool yeah
well I thought I almost found it
oh man this is extensive they went all
out like you can get lost in this van
made map ooh this looks like where you
meet Moaning Myrtle not the bathroom but
like where you meet her and another
forget I think it was in the Oh which
book was that her movie I should say oh
when you when Harry's looking for her
for the Horcrux well according to the
compass you're about to just hop into
class Oh break my legs for this class
and you're like early still what the
worst Snape like is late hmm blue
network in the chat fast travel to the
Great Hall and head across a huge bridge
out there you should be able to find it
from there oh nice protein to that like
flu powder blue Network that's its flu
network in the trash
the fire is because the minimap thing
dang you guys are all appear in the chat
thanks for joining us this is amazing
[Music]
we're freaking out and now we just want
to watch the movies
all right so yes this is a huge bridge
oh wow where's mad-eye moody now he's
not here
yay cuz he says good morning guys wow
dude do we get to play footage thanks
for being this is hi to you too spy
hunter hope you like Harry Potter or my
is it written in blood I don't like how
this sounds oh it was that little
question mark that he was looking at on
the wall right there I think your mind
mi Nam's disregard I did he was looking
at ya
the first clue is found though for yet
remain follow these clues free for each
cell explain where next to go in this
hunt for riches pursued by determined
wizard and which is fun hey look Jeff
Jeff is is talking to the flute Network
he's a big fan
look at that connecting people here at
GameSpot Hazim you want to know who made
this masterpiece flue network right
there honestly I feel so special that
they're tuning into it for a second I
was like wait is that is that from like
the discord side like the flue network I
had a like Oh what is it you're trying
to do now it's so deep like in chicken
and detailed that Hazim who made this
masterpiece look up like five chats
above you flu network or if you want to
check out the description of this video
you can also download it and check out
the discord server alright so now I know
if I ever really wasn't immigrants my
ass I'd be late to every class ever get
kicked out
Transfiguration grows its figuration we
don't use Transfiguration as a
punishment remember when
Malfoy got turned into a little weasel
[Music]
all right so we know this isn't the one
we need Jeff was just clowning with us
he's like that was a joke I talked to
them every day
or at least a lot yeah Oh got night it
got turned dark so quickly I know that's
how long it's taken me to find this
glasses flu Network has a protip look
for the signs on the walls it's
difficult to find a way around at first
but later on you can fast travel so that
helps we did see some signs with the
fingers like this let go here mm-hmm
we're just trying to get to class it's
been two days
[Laughter]
I don't know everyone really or if I've
gone too far no 500 we have to ask Eric
T about the specs of this computer it's
pretty updated but it's not like all the
way maxed out we'll have to get back to
you on that some other time but we
should know that here never been so
excited to attend class welcome hmm
time to learn Lumos baby Wow hmm what
that's cool
ash are you still there cuz that's dope
or I don't know if he knew that
scattered throughout the maze of the
corridors and returned to me to complete
all right you got it
huh Hazim says wow that details so
amazing is there any chance to encounter
with that one of the options are one of
the missions was to go or to get lost in
the what was it the woods or oh yeah go
explore the forbidden for it yeah so hmm
later so I'm going to go find all five
stars in the dark maze oh it is very
dark already what that actually Mouse
time to call it out wait I missed it did
you actually learn it yeah or like this
is your way to learn it yeah I think
what did it say it's bright enough for
you to see we'll be the judge of that
normy turn off that light in front of
you that helped last time
Oh coz that is a bold-faced lie oh I
feel like well there we go all right can
I actually is it okay okay I just must
really go this way that's we're not
agreeing that I think I just have to
walk deeper in into the darkness how
about now oh no Jeff is like raise the
brightness but uh it's I don't think
that was an issue before let me turn off
this light I'm just scared the lake okay
here we go now keep there we go oh I
just had to walk deep enough into the
the darkness for it to work
oh what's that flim-flam it's not all
right let me just in case I will do it
that helped a little bit okay all right
there we go
holy is my life right yeah I'll come
down to the chat are you doing don't
make me do that who says I think your
brightness is very low compared to most
people hey man yeah maybe so that's true
but uh we got Lumos now yeah good thing
we're not timed I'd be freaking out oh
wow oh my god half man I came there
oh man if something pops out of me right
now y'all definitely the lack of music
does add a little hmm
and now that it's dark there's one
alright
[Music]
Yusef in the chasis I'm eating Chipotle
right now yeah love Chipotle what do you
get what's your order I like the chicken
bowl yep guac cheese sour cream nice oh
I like their medium spice salsa
they have good hot salsa but it's kind
of Opie yeah it sapote leave my life
like the good old vine I love that blue
Network there's one every time I look
over it's like you found one I should
just stick lock my eyes on this screen
give me a sec Chad I'm gonna zero flu
network says we're working on getting
music for the map it's one of the last
things before the final release very
cool it's so nice to have you here flute
blue Network is like they're just here
on the sidelines like helping us explain
what's going on and giving us the
insight love it and all the bugs man my
sense of direction
Yussef says am I the only one who does a
special order for that chicken ball
though what do you do
I like they're so free to us too
I went on this Oh with guacamole is
extra put down another dollar like say
less man I'm here okay there was a
little map I was like what map are you
talking about the marauders map no no
there's one what your name is Chipotle
is my life and you only eat the chips I
don't believe you I'm not 4 out of 500
to the right where you're in the red
spot right yeah okay oh wow that one's
furthest farthest away you got this
photographic memory wrappers yeah thank
you guys for putting a map at every
league that is that is cool dude ooh now
you're doing fine you have four out of
five
[Music]
do you remember Persia like something
like this was emphasized in the books
about how you learn and use Lumos like
some little quiz yeah and when they
learned the bad spells and no one wants
to do it cuz they test on bugs that
scared me a little bit just Jeff thanks
for being here friend it's 1:00 a.m.
where Jeff is and he's got to go
tomorrow at 6:00 come back sometime hope
you have a wonderful day he says thank
you for being here it was nice having
you on board and for your help you
helped us out in the beginning
didn't do you think he's so much nice
talking to your friend alright yep now
get great now you just have to GTFO oh
no oh no least you have to jump on
anything really I just need to like 180
go straight you got it that was
extensive
but like you earned Lumos okay oh good
another map yes yes yes stupefy sweet oh
cool I wonder which one you got Nicholas
Flamel
you're all your food yeah we know who
teaches that class actually and this
first book it's not Snape facting like
the first like three that's the job he
always wants but can never get it's like
mad-eye moody quarrel everyone but Snape
he should feel lucky
because it was cursed anyways yeah
allies if you check our description it's
a it's a map fan-made Harry Potter map
that took many many years to make the
library so definitely a labor of love
definitely do the quests logs but there
aren't specific ones oh okay gotcha
thank you whoa I'm about to throw up
is there an elevator they even got her
glasses the notice boards
I did see a notice for it somewhere we
were walking might have been on the
other side that's okay this sounds well
actually this is not a side quest I was
like a the greenhouses yeah where's
Neville Hogg's needs over here Irene
since we're just about it's just about
time for us to I know I'm sad it's just
about time wait I want to I want to go
look at Hogsmeade before we left maybe
she meant it was over here wasn't it
straight ahead I don't know it is you're
going to Hagrid's place
the Quidditch field it totally is look
it's rendered in now oh my god
it's the time at which we can fly I want
to see all of this
I'm deadly and down with us at home
Elias really I don't want to build that
man thank you cuz if so holy crap
we did have flu powder in here earlier
so I'm willing to believe anything now
Network the whole crew it's there well
done Gryffindor Wow
we miss Hagrid a little Hut though at
its finest a supreme example of like
what you can do in Minecraft crazy you
probably get in Weasley twins again yeah
let's play some Quidditch alright
what's-her-name who teaches Oh madam
hooch oh yeah that's boys he actually
looks like the Gryffindor leader oh yeah
[Music]
hmm it's wood that's of course of course
we got to find hooch how do you get it
for Xbox chubby toe I'm not sure if
that's an option at the moment I think
it's just PC hmm oh we can go inside we
can go in the tent lieutenant you
remember when they did the Triwizard cup
and they were in the tent before they
wants to go fight the dragon do I that's
where they like that's where they figure
out which dragon they're gonna fight
right the little eggs you're here
it's beautiful like wow this would be a
okay
okay I started moving the mouse real
slow because I was like wow
[Music]
the memories right yes I remember when
they actually sandwich that girl into
the oh yeah yeah those are wooden hairy
and mouth wired down they're kicking
each other like trying to chase the
Golden Snitch man this is awesome it's
so impressive yes thank you guys so much
for making this Matt because I feel like
I was non-stop smiling this entire time
playing this and I'm definitely gonna
play more of it can't wait to see the
final version but hey like I would be
totally happy with this that this was
final as is and and I love it I think
it's awesome I think it's way better
than that mobile Harry Potter game they
cannot the Very Potter go but the other
one had to like cast spells and stuff oh
I didn't play that other one that's like
oh you know press it costs one coin to
do research or something this was way
more fun I had a blast and I'm
definitely be playing more of this soon
hope you guys enjoyed the stream and
enjoyed hanging out with us sorry we
were a little bit late but we really
wanted to make sure that we got this up
and running so we did and it's good but
keep in mind that every single weekday
at 2:00 p.m. Pacific time any time we
are live with various games new and old
and created by fans yeah please tune in
we'd love to see you and until next time
bye you guys
you